we're both on the east coast and we're
both italian-americans so I was like
heating up all pasta from the night
before in the kitchen on the frying pan
we were eating on the patio talking
about life and family and then he wanted
to sing with me a song by Creedence
Clearwater Revival Midnight Special so I
was playing it on the piano and he
started to sing and I was like oh my
gosh Bradley your voice I was blown away
by him I mean he just he sings from his
soul he sings from his gut and when he
sings he's a Storyteller and I was just
so moved by his passion you know for for
the for music and for this film and
quite frankly it was him that had to
convince other people to have me in the
movie you can have a hundred people in
the room that are watching you and 99
don't believe in you and one does and
that was him